enjoying ourselves tonight because
celebrate we gotta celebrate life man
we're breathing we're walking it's
incredible
it's incredible daniel kaluya took home
the oscar for best supporting actor
and shocked his mom with a sex joke
during his acceptance speech
my mum my dad they had sex it's amazing
like
i'm saying i'm here you know i mean so
i'm so happy to be alive
so i'm going to celebrate that tonight
the 32 year old nabbed the honor for
playing late
black panther chairman fred hampton in
judas and the black messiah
[Applause]
and when he took the stage to accept his
academy award
he was quick to give a special shout out
to his mom
who was in the audience along with his
sister i
thought my mom thank you so much for
pouring in to me
you gave me everything you gave me your
factory settings
so i can stand at my fullest height the
actor continued his speech by thanking
the late hampton and his family
including his one surviving son as well
as the black panthers for their impact
on his life
and others they showed me how to love
myself
and with that love they overflowed it to
the black community and to other
communities
and they showed us that the power of
union power of unity
that when they play divide and conquer
we say unite and ascend
and while daniel went on to say that
there's so much work to do
and that it's on everyone in this room
he also took a moment to celebrate the
miracles of life
celebrate we've got to celebrate life
man we're breathing we're walking it's
incredible
it's incredible like it's incredible my
mom met my dad
they had sex it's amazing like you're
saying i'm here
you know i mean so i'm so happy to be
alive
so i'm going to celebrate that tonight
yeah that totally shocked
daniel's mom and sister and if you look
closely at his mom
it appears she's saying what is he
talking about
naturally that moment went viral and
daniel's friend
michael b jordan took to his instagram
story to share his reaction to the
whole thing yeah boy yes d
thank you
protection yes sir
they had sex it's amazing oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh this boy fool
hey so what does daniel's mom have to
say about
all that here's what he told e.t in the
press room after his big win
i really shouldn't have said that you
know dan you have you had a chance to
talk to your mom yet
has she texted oh bro no no i'm gonna
avoid my phone for a bit mate
trust me i'm gonna avoid my phone for a
bit i think my mom's not gonna be very
happy
but she's gonna be cool she's gonna be
cool nice she's gonna be cool she's just
like she knows she's got a sense of
humor so she like we give it to each
other so
it's cool
you